une production du studio sf
bio venus sans fenêtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut nous inviter
d'actifs chez bh quand tu es avec moi
d'une plante y est j'ai décidé qu'on
élève que je n'allais rien ploguer qu'on
allait juste jamais un peu sur l'intro
parce que tu sais pourquoi
tu sais que je fais le podcast hippiques
la wii sur le podcast ou piquionne
je dis n'importe quoi va mal en métro
quelqu'un qui a fait ses comptes le
métro est ce que tout ça c'est pas tout
le temps la même chose qui revient plus
après 209
le podcast j'ai décidé qu'on allait
enfin être au plus tard fustal dans
laquelle flamatt bloque un peu par la
bad trip à cast away à l'écouté
mais pour ça je faisais ça c'était
vraiment
super se souvient des looks plus tôt que
j'ai pensé même aux jo maintenant tu
aimerais tu sais que j'ai
pu
[Musique]
la chaîne explique à chaque semaine
chaque semaine mais j'aurais fourni à
chaque semaine on va revenir sur une
femme théorie de star ou x non mais sans
déconner d'abandonner une source
[Musique]
bessat et des sables forme sans fond des
jardins de matériel de jupons comme par
les
limites que l'on est plus que ça c'est
vrai qu'on peut tu les plus que ce
[Musique]
mais cette semaine
on ensuite les pièces en or 6 litres aux
attentes pas des bombes maintenant mais
mais
c'est incroyable quand même juste pour
faire une réflexion plus macro
on avait 12 ans quand les trois accords
ont explosé et le même des années plus
tard le certains pourraient même dire 18
ans plus tard et il vient du podcast
pour
leur ai dit que j
[Musique]
écoutais t
a doublement steak pré-ado maintenant
qu'il ya vraiment marqué à tige album là
c'est tout le temps
hawaiian
saskatchewan team je me souviens été on
avait un pansement s'appelle du cil puis
la tombe du ciel encore
autant que
bojan
mais parce que c'est de nature
mais spécialement du monde quantique est
quand même marqué un peu le
nom les années formatrices et formatrice
à ce qu'on découvre la musique lyrique
c'est comme ses hôtes je trouve super
crise ont une chance aux ouais
ouais chaque semaine ils trop d'accord
on a parlé de plein fouet par les deux
en fait les justement leur début de
carrière il l'explosion de tout sous
serment intéressant c'était loin c'est
l'égalité
des d'une vingtaine étaient étudiants
pires provinces album le thé avec
qui j'étais sérieux de leur démarche
pense que ces personnes peut s'attendre
à face et est ce que ça explose comme ce
ppi puis en russie comme acquis aussi
con quand réussi à perdurer dans le
temps puis à se renouveler pillards a
tout le temps à regarder les lgv est
l'intérêt de faire un bon album après
vol à bord a très bel album
c'est vraiment un outil vraiment dégueu
extrêmement tendancieux l'escip le pari
c'est impressionnant quand même coach
quand on creuse un petit peu plus
profondément dans les élus expliqué le
commandant parle pas de casse dalle est
bon le deuxième degré le deuxième niveau
des trois accords qui est présent même
si beaucoup de personnes s'en rendent
même pas compte en écoutant les mélodies
accrocheuses clé les la musique les
téléphones du mot puisque seulement en
forme et ont un cinéma c'est alors
qu'une comédie va gagner ailleurs film
aux oscars c'est comme si le mot c'est
comme si c'était un des fois pris moins
au sérieux que le temps que le drame ou
que justement les lie la chanson de ce
[Musique]
type à l'allemand qui est meilleur parce
que c'est plus facile puisque
l'allemagne est vraiment un talent
d'écriture pyromane ya tout le temps
double sens et temps des belles images
et le temps des idées les thématiques et
que tu avais pas pensé ok
puis on a parlé aussi l'oeil c'est la
quinzième du festival de la poutine
c'est le festival qui ont start up on a
parlé de la jamaïque du festival on ne
parlait comment s'était lancé les
différentes difficultés qui ont eu à
surmonter
ça aussi c'est vraiment intéressant
c'est quand même un gros presque quinze
ans les à cette histoire qui a organisé
un événement puis un événement de grande
envergure car non seulement c'est bing
seberg voudrait être le
la première journée de jeudi judy fait
d'une voix je connais bien tout honneur
allez voir sur le site web joue avec
ariane droit sinon il ya vraiment un
artiste
jours le cycle et le tir au
biberon machines coûtent par là dessus
on a déjà statué sur les trophées quand
vous vous laissez à leur conversation
bon paquet bonne écoute
et solide mais nous le podcast et
prétendez promène tchèque mène skype
c'est parmi nos commandites a préféré
sipa notre commentateur préféré sur
l'autoroute a20 de kate son look tout le
temps sont là avec nous ayons les
meilleurs produits d'entretien pour pour
le corps mais reproduit à côté pour les
cordes de loin
[Musique]
je dis ça j'exagère faut on en parle
souvent on rêve sûrement skate sans
arrêt mais il ya une raison pour ce la
raison pas vous le dire
c'est que c'est les meilleurs produits
mais si vous voulez un package ou est-ce
que tout c'est le platine un paquet qui
n'ont pas pu embarquer de tout ce qu'ils
avaient besoin pour être heureux yu
premièrement you de l'amoureux 4.0 qui
le rasoir électrique que vous voyez ici
sur cette vidéo de voiliers ceux qui
sont en haut doubs il faut la table
c'est le meilleur et waterproof skins ça
faisait qui est pas mal il va vraiment
super bien musique de loin le meilleur
tour électrique que j'ai jamais utilisé
bref sinon il ya les produits pour la
douche les body wash le shampoing moi
c'est mon match je suis honnête mange
toujours un ton d'un blog
parce que tu es en fait je prends une
douche tout le temps en train de mettre
benoît jean bouin des champions et de
marne ont ils démontrent que pour
utiliser de produits utilisés jeu sera
utilisé pour me brosser les dents ce
contenu
moi j'ai un gros fan du bruit doit que
willie walker si polis pour khaled passé
commente enchaînant ses clips télé c'est
pour les poils de nez puis les poils de
réussissent jamais
moi quand je sais pas me voir ma blonde
escales l'amfar calmes et on se couche
et sud au caveau des poils de nez à
prendre et wallonie les hlm pour est
douloureux et pas très agréable fac j'ai
pas fou je suis mon lillois que pour
calais rien sur le coup de série ce nom
et c'est sans arrêt sa clé wi doigt que
je le conseille pour tout le monde qui
ont
des blondes que l'album qui ont juste le
goût d'avoir des belles marine belle
clean clean on a un code promo pour vous
c'est le sans filtre 20% de rabais je
suis pas gratuit sauter là dessus merci
mme kay merci à vous bon bah tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais pour qu'elle sache alors qu'eric
fait comme zéro de la musique le ps qui
dans les niayes vous avez dernier unique
à chacun où est ce que tu peux choisir
comme le niveau de tout fait le mec
c'est comme et comme particuliers en
importe tout le monde et c'est en
général c'était contre le mix de bâton
six musiciens sur scène tu écoutes du
sismics différend
n'est pas ta qui pourrait vivre avec le
mix de n'importe qui à peu près juin
mais c'est sûr que des trucs qui peuvent
être lourdement
sur tous les chanteurs va-t-il aider des
gens qui chantent comme sinon ce sera le
cas dans son mix y apportant des idées
qui borde et puis de voir percussions
autant que - dont on est sûr que son mix
hip hop là tu as écouté mais ça c'est
vraiment bon mais que les paroles de
voir avec ma guitare
[Rires]
comme show live c'est lui qui sonne le
plus comme ce que le mot l'entendement
folle zac sauf que y'a du clairement
ford
way est ce que vous avez toujours joué
sur le clic vos shows live ben moi je
mangeais
j'étais esclave du clic seul longtemps
ah ouais
ça comme réglé un truc abandonnés ou
deux c'est comme l'impression
d'accélérer ou de ralentir et on a parlé
après joue pas donner ça comme chez moi
je rejoue clé on va régler ça descend ça
va que c'est tout vous autres qui voient
mais c'est vrai qu'au début il première
tournée on ne voit pas de cliquer piste
est vraiment gentil step ou si vous avez
vous le temps d'écouter ça on se
promenait le quitter jolie fille lily
très bonne question d'opinion les gens
trouvent simplement
de
chocolat tourné avant c'est vraiment que
c'est maintenant par un chauffard et
légaux pour rire l'hôtel town vous l'a
filé trop si je peux pas courir après
vous aurez toujours chez moi vous devez
me rejoindre dans ce groupe il ya des
tonnes quand je jouais
quand j'aurais même pu un peu à cause de
ces comme vice et le steampunk y en a
plusieurs années on l'a pas vraiment à
jouer le fils de 7 ou non là on a
repeint pas cool le territoire et apcom
paulson a joué club le fc sur le site
laisse finalement bien vos super bientôt
que j'ai l'impression que c'est pas
étranger au fait que justement la tire
tout le monde un meilleur film et deux
temps puis aussi c'est tout le monde
s'entend mieux tout symptôme qu'on est
capable de mieux
c'est fou quand même déjà
d'avoir cet apprentissage le
dans des gros shows parce que quand vous
avez commencé les choses jamais vraiment
été petit pour l'été il ya eu des
diarrhées des
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
petits shows le sait juste que les gens
nous on a commencé vraiment radio
universitaire s'est parlé d'université
dans les barthes se fait c'était ça a
été deux trois ans quand même de ces
deux choses un peu comme ce temps jouait
dans des cgp le midi avant
bamenda parce que telle et les chaussons
petite amende avance keith amor tout ce
que tu fais dans votre effectif des
trucs dans mame qui qui font un peu
l'histoire mais mon ca fois que j'essaie
de créer aussi au festival en tant que
programmateur c'est que des fois qu'un
artiste vraiment vraiment d'avant ce
soit le magazine slate qui
correct pour lui au moment où le bloc
par rapport à sa popularité puis quand
tu arrives au show des fois cinq six
sept mois guerre blues de quoi le fait
que le bordel ça fait ça pour nous puis
c'est souvent des trucs qui sont
vraiment les femmes un cégep qui vous
bouffe pour l'heure du midi aps le vote
album sort
il ya eu ceux ci dcg vous c'est pas ça
la banque a relevé le
choc en vendée où il avait mis à côté de
la caisse
assistait à côté de la caisse dans la
cafétéria
qui y avait une statine je pense qu'une
élève nom de la dame la cafétéria la
caisse irak était une voix mené pendant
le show lanzarote nous
pierre vadi pour y voir et c'est
vraiment genre gaussin pour mac est
petit si on faisait moins mêlée on est
engagé fait qu'il faudrait qu'on fait
note chaque tacle allait l'arrêter mais
il ya eu ça aussi c'est pas le bébé mais
des fois mais mais c'est
une goutte booking la prod de choses
était pour moi un peuple déjà mangé 20
mai mais c'est vrai que
c'est là un des trucs on se parlait
maintenant à woodstock en beauce mais je
suis vous avez bouquet dans l'attenté je
pense que c'est attendre découverte là
puis c'était juste au moment où mes
tantes et 15 hockey c'était jean six
mois avant que vraiment que ça lève le à
l'été 2004 bah ça comme un bon
shoot avoir un enfant non joué selon lui
par thoune vers sitruk en mai mais ce
n'est pas ton peut pas faire comme étant
des métropolitains quand on est arrivé à
webster qu'il restait le moment où là
c'est devenu comme connu a vraiment plus
largement
pillay a noté dans petite tente puis
avait genre je pense la tente de prouver
qu'on dérange pas 3 400 personnes n'y
avait eu un temps comme de vertige dans
des revues du monde à l'extérieur
l'attend vraiment loin c'était vraiment
un coup notre devenir maman ça va mal tu
étais de certains étaient de ceux où
abandonné son fauteuil beaucoup de
premières parties avec les vulgaires
machins
cd emi
enfin nous celle à mal à se financer
comme fameuse histoire de qui selon show
commence une tournée en est un
le opening acte qui après la tournée
c'est quand même
le gars était pas que ça marchait pas
c'est ça ma des salles de 5,6 à sa
personne mais il y avait le public des
bulgares le dépliant pluie avec des
trois accords
qui vous voyez
ça doit être réel plaisir de vivre ça ce
qu'ils étaient vraiment ils étaient une
vingtaine on a ce qu'on nous a quittés
j'imagine qu'il s'attend jamais à blois
club et espère que ça soit ce titre la
musique dans la vie pour vous fonctionne
fait que c'est sûr que quand ça commence
à marcher comme ça il ya deux
mecs feeling parce qu'ils étaient
d'avoir ya un exemple qui envoie le la
grosse planche le thé invité dans toutes
les émissions télé tout ces trucs là
pour la farine ou non seul truc qu'on
sait c'est que l'année d'avant à voir il
y en avait explosé mais ce sont les
radios universitaires mais on savait
qu'après il y avait eu saskatchewan
d'autres
notre consulat ce moment restés les
chaussons super le fun c'est vraiment
cool ça blois tout le monde laissant
tout mon fils ils étaient calmes mais
faut c'est faux le mec c'est fou que la
prochaine tournée en bac il faut que tu
ne fais rien de saskatchewan après
d'autres faits en fait vous avez déjà eu
le souci pas être honnêtement exactement
factions sont invités dans des émissions
télévisées genre chaque fois que vous
pourriez faire avoir rien de plus ont
préparé des petites structures comme un
registre on veut juste faire
saskatchewan petit pont sur le prochain
je sais même pas si on a déjà et on a
joué à voir rien de tel que font dans
des émissions c'est vraiment
des premiers messages ils ont refusé
beaucoup d'affaires aussi ça faisait
c'était bizarre pour le monde on avait
une approche mais
sait on plus plu parce qu'en fait on
obtient on et ont-ils venir les grands
dans les petites antilles du skate punk
durant impuretés comme un peu on venait
de titres vont peut-être des amis ici on
était calmes puis on était sur un les
beautés un discours qui était super
indépendant csif est compté comme un peu
je pense que ça
c'était vraiment le fun pour ça aussi
mais ce terrain on avait probablement la
paire fois que je m'imagine de
l'extérieur
c'est juste qu'on avait vraiment les
temps c'est vrai ce que chardy on
voulait que c'est peut-être suite la
réaction aussi du monde de dire comme
steam je me suis né jours nous le steak
sommes au début c'était comme un ça va
jamais levé près c'était comme ça ok ça
livre ça va être vraiment foot pas fait
le steak m on savait comme je le disais
que ça c'est qu'ils avaient de quoi
d'autre en arrière qu'on voulait pousser
ce fait que je me suis un prénom n'a été
évité à la fureur on ne peut pas aller
oui mais on avait accepté dans la télé
qui y
est
ça fait partie du
même pas faire la france est très
conscient qu'il faut quitter la série
human sa
tournée avant les troubles
qui agitent avec olivier la pige en jeu
devenu vraiment bon qu'il répare ce que
tu as à sec un pro qui les gens dans des
trucs mais salah niaiseux mais après
c'était juste le meilleur hockeyeur
oligos
chaque a vraiment un bon
gars des
organistes école c'est comme pas deux
clips dalphond le feicom votre premier
gros y est qui et comment on veut pas
que cette crypte qu'on ne tolère aimé
jouer par exemple qu'on a toujours joué
à ce jeu les mets tes proches de pages
web rien
qu'à joue maintenant tout le monde est
content
j'étais content qu'elle fasse pas mal et
ça c'est nos discussions mais les
crs que chardy qu'on l'a jamais passé
proche de paul a joué par exemple sont
toujours des fiascos chanson l'appui on
était on était content de la jouer
pierre c'est normal quand on a joué un
besoin c'est
cette conversation m
sais tu disais qu'il y avait des
journaux qui écrivent être soi ça va
être un feu de paille soit c'est déjà
terminé tu sais moi j'ai lu dans mon
foyer chez nous là mon père il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de musique berne est
arrivé chez nous je me rappelle je m'en
rappelle encore avec votre album en dix
ans écoutez se plaignent du fait de
jouer en moyenne puis 10 seule sa est un
band que vous allez entendre parler
pendant un fini de danser moi j'ai
entendu envoyant pendant ce temps-là
j'écoutais j'écoute du depeche mode si
j'étais vraiment pas dans le pot dans
cette ambiance le biologique en fait non
gentil je le vois pas nécessairement
retirer avec ceux des cités comme
saveurs rejoignez pas tant que ça c'est
pas un album qui sonne est
particulièrement bien entendu je sais
que 2000 pièces et ça ce n'est sa sonné
mais pop rock garage mais ça ce n'est
quand même des banques perdait rugby
mais la fed à schiphol et où il y avait
finalement mais moi à chaque fois à
chaque fois que vous ressortez quelque
chose à chaque fois que kylie trois
accords reviennent avec un nouvel album
nouveau single niveau mon pari me
rappelle tout le temps a dit je te
l'avais dit de fait j'ai grandi 10 ou
doute l'été 2004 2004 j'avais
j'arrêterai un fait que j'aime j'ai
grandi puis écoutez vous êtes encore
parce qu'à ce moment-là ya vingt dix et
au nord de maisons dix mois l'album qui
te kamal ben oui j'aurais dit oui parce
que non mais je me rappelle encore pis
si tu es vraiment son corps le puil il
avait raison et couvre un salut les who
on salue les eaux et repos il n'y a pas
d'équivalent sentent ils influencent
pong même temps c'était petit matin à
rabat une clé steam et dans l'énergie
dans l'attitude métier cashman town
country pas précisé pis des d'incorporer
lumeau là dedans comme moi à l'époque
que j'ai entendu ce nom mais ton t on
avait 12 ans est sorti chez moi je me
suis dit le phénomène que c'était je
suis du clip dans le chalet et puis on
m'a clairement tourné en pellicule ah
ouais c'est ce coup ci la classent à
l'époque
tel pot qui amuse plus jouer vraiment un
rôle important l'impression d'en haut
comme les rats absolument développement
des artistes qui
jouaient à côté et puis quoi je pense
que pour je pense qu'elles pourront nous
c'est ça qui est qui je me suis aperçu
peter que
pour nous ça clash est patent on savait
que c'était comme passe-temps basque on
faisait c'était quand même mais pour
nous ça a clashé patin dans des corps je
pense autant que pour les autres je
pense que c'est juste une
super équipe lâcher parce que en
comparaison avec qu'est ce que nous on
écoutait plus belle qu'on aimait et puis
regardez les les vulgaires machins et
les marmottes aplatit et illico bref
rien qui avait déjà quelques albums et
comme ce n'était pas un
texte les thématiques c'était quand même
plus plus tôt ce mois ci c'est la fin
qui est arrivé je pense que à la base de
tout cela est parti à la base d'un d'un
coup de foudre pour pas l'épaule et
s'éviter de ce test est amoureux
d'humour absurde de cet angle le fait qu
après ce bain
d'enfants pour nous autres en fait de le
rapprocher de la musique qui étaient
plus des mets ton de le prendre et
mandingue musicale diront qu'ils vont
faire des bonnes tout nous ont offert
les meilleures chansons qu'on peut faire
métier en étant conscient qu'il y avait
toute cette comme chardy avait divulgué
y avait les cowboys avaient mara
tremblay même si quand il faut l'écouter
fred fortin c'est son premier album
factice était comme vraiment
c'était pas si woods en fait c'était
juste l'argent d'où l'intérêt que vous
aviez quitté - maurel&prom unis d'abord
puis le possesseur mais ce rêve pour
nous c'était comme d'incorporer ceux de
cette manière là mais ce n'est pas comme
si si woods ont tendance à être en fait
un combat pour le monde apprécie quand
tu reviens sans le plus visité j'ai des
discussions des fouilles du mans qui
remet en cause d'arrivée le mouche comme
si c'était tellement champ gauche je
pense que c'est ça aussi le thé pour un
étudiant se popularise enfants sic car
sa radio peut nous allons rester que
leur geste
underground je dois
je penser j'en trouvais ça très très
choquant gauche au début le ti la radio
soleil était comme un peu beaucoup pour
le monde ce n'était pas dans ses dents
les trucs que nous on aimait le dessus
quand tu regardes jeunesse que weezer
faisait un album bien en vidéo clés pour
bien qu'aux élites ou des trucs comme ça
on était dans cette lignée là pour nous
faire un clip sur la loire yam l'hiver
n'était pas c'était mieux mais c'était
pas comme
pour nos artistes et come with aurait
fait sa place à 6,27 la moyenne
mais oui je me suis encore car on
chantait c'est dans la cour d'école puis
on dit même si moi je me rappelle les
lits les couleurs de l'école si mettons
les véhicules chantait sauce ils
n'existaient pas c'était plus réservé
justo elle voulait que ses fils de dieu
un peu mous dit kiki qui écoute des
affaires oui comme tout le monde chantal
francke ans a joué toutes les tout peu
importe c'est quoi ton champ d'intérêt
musical je la connais nous on venait
aussi de ceux d'un truc ou si tu avais
le snowboard et ski t on aligne entre
les deux têtes et faisait du camping
cars
d'écouter cette musique l'os musique
l'oeuf pourri comme des délits comme
subi ce test pour nous autres cas le
procureur s'est faite de passer cédé
juste des coquilles à l'université qui
sont des polypes tout à genre il ya des
enfants dans nos shows de dix grands
parents dans l'eau chaude est une
adaptation d'un titre à thomas qu'il
sait plus qui ne publie que ses projets
ses prix ce qui montre qu'ils traitent
aussi sur le monde arabe et qu'elle s'en
allait en fait dans la dans la crainte
puisque diversifie diversifié au point
vous avez presque inquiétant de venir
pour nous était un truc était comme pas
cools et puis au fil du temps c'est
comme en médecine suit pas le fond de
ces chaudes puis ça marche les festivals
sont plaints du ciel depuis sa yam il ya
quand même transition qui se fait de
deux commencé à avoir de plus en plus de
monde qui sont pas comme ton s'est on
bosse
comme tout le monde qui personnes ont
accès mais si vous les arabes ateliers
je pense qu'il ya aussi un moment où
c'était comme
genre dans nos têtes parce que damian
puis je me suis lancé d'olivier vraiment
être tellement conceptuel ce qu'on
faisait ce thème s'est très
c'est un trip à la base relativement
cérébrale quand même c'est comme ça
que vous saviez vous lirez l'instinct là
dedans mais dans le sens où si c'était
comme si c'était conceptuel le mettons
me de penser que le monde allait tromper
sur hawaii m dans ma tête c'est concept
de demande à quelqu'un est un des
meilleurs tic était vraiment mais
finalement quand ça a levé c'était comme
le step et ce tout le monde le sait
aussi qu'ils étaient là ça sera de 60
pour le monde ils démontrent sans cercle
du concept dans le gros lot il y en a
peut-être 10% des gens qui répète mais
la part des gentilhommes la mélodie
trouve qu'elle mossad mouche pas
qu'est-ce qui fait quelques clubs et ça
a été de se rendre compte si que les
gens
aiment et ce pour l'heure chacun leurs
raisons
puis le fait que pour ceux commandés
avec 1,9 sentiment de dire à qui sait
pas la main assez speed c'est parce que
c'est super c'est plutôt consensuelles
comme à faire plus que les malades ou je
sais pas quoi d'autre rejoindre les
demandes de ses succès comme je disais
qu'il y des enfants d'un show il ya les
enfants chantent hawaïenne et en plus je
me suis invitée comme on met les enfants
comprennent pas qu'on
dise pas garde
on skie second faire c'est tant mieux
ils vont juste prendre ce qu'ils aiment
la d'un pigeon on vivre sur comme
justement c'est ça sort de ton contrôle
depuis ça devient comme un autre à faire
partie avant je pense pour nous autres
ça a été il ya eu un il ya eu des étapes
de d'où les gens ont juste pris ça pour
ce que voulaient pique était des fois
même pas notre intention à la base mais
c'est juste devenu ce depuis un an je
pense qu'avec le temps on a appris à
apprécier
aussi même a fait rapidement team que
ben coudonc s'écoule tant mieux dit jean
si les gens il
qu'est ce que ça fait c'est que les gens
qu'il cache pas le concept derrière ses
sketches aux programmes ces gens
une fois qu'ils s'acquittent
vaudois vos têtes ça appartient aux
personnes qui le reçoit
c'est pour moi c'est clair que
maintenant dans des marchés trop
d'accord il
ya un sérieux qui vraiment c'est
justement dans les concerts des tournées
aussi dans la musique c'était tous des
anciens qui utilisent album
depuis de plus en plus maintenant qu'un
c'est le premier album on l'attend que
c'est plus au fait avec les moyens
ça se voit qu'il est vraiment une
démarche qui sérieuse puisque ça tu
étais comme
cette ut chiant déboute de genre et
les bords et puis comme on sait qu'en
plus ce qu'ils font mais oui mais je me
souviens très bien que au 2e ou 3e album
on s'est assis puis on a dit on va dire
aux gens qu'on travaille parce qu'on
était menti moi je me dis c'était
tellement évident le matin c'était super
ce qu'on travaille écoute les textes vos
banques et j'en fais penser le tai chi
et ouais même si c'est de l'absurde et
je travaille en arrière mais non
finalement c'est
[Rires]
comme il y avait un peu une vague de
ils ont été chanceux sur les deux
prochains albums cette vague là un peu
comme de la classe et piste et il y
avait pu faire des entrevues toujours
toujours toujours assez absurde jamais
répondre aux questions tout ça m'a donné
sa salle alimente s le ton espèce de
truc puis on a commencé à créer une
image qu'on ne sait pas ce que mon poste
moi beaucoup moins à l'aise avec la ces
comme
j'avais 14 ans je vais faire la musique
d'un film assez gpt fin mars le cas par
malchance le thé ou par chance le tc que
c'est comme ça c'est toujours ce que je
lui fasse mon gré des tonnes à 14 15 ans
jouent ensemble est toujours écrit des
tonnes toujours fait de la musique fait
madani et comme un genre de ça pour être
cool une fois sur brûlis ou une fois sur
trois ans répond aux questions
faso pour frédéric ce
qu'on s'applique à faire des bons
chemins qu'on s'applique à faire des
bonnes tonnes qu'on s'applique à ce que
même qu' un travail sérieux derrière
cette affaire le qui a leur a laissé
tomber aussi avec un album où il y avait
dans mon corps en série du médecin s'il
y avait des tonneaux 6 août céline le
thème clank devenait de plus en plus
clair puis c'était un peu moins flou
aussi le tenant dans la main dans les
sujets fait je pense le deuxième c'est
le deuxième degré était quand même plus
facile d'accès surtout pour monsieur
madame tout le monde je pense que
hawaï en faux quand pose la question le
proposer au delà du refrain catchy matin
saskatchewan aussi seppi j'ai
l'impression que vous avez quand même
réussi un peu le tour de force de fort à
qui on vous allez nous écouter parce
mais après ça vous allez écouter nos
messages quand qui deviennent peut-être
plus apparent plus clair plus tard d'en
retirer c'est juste arrivé même si c'est
simon 6-4 qui aura fini son écriture qui
a trouvé une manière de
faire des tonnes dans mon accent de
communes tout d'un bon mais mais à la 3
à 4 et 5 ça sonne comme c'est comme une
toune qui pourrait être
une manière de chanter une tonne d'amour
de car le pirate que
si celle est rôti
monde là mais je pense qu'il ya eu c'est
ça il ya eu d'exploration aussi quand
même premier album deuxième album
beaucoup il y avait vraiment on était
consciente il m'a même dit qu'on allait
en prendre place pour essayer quand on
extrait seul exclure cette manière de
chanter leur c'est un petit certains
thèmes
fakaté je pense que d'arriver après
justement dans une chanson comme dans
mon corps ou des trucs comme ceux qui
vraiment plus simple mais là où on
pouvait utiliser même lexique qu'on
avait utilisé l'un d'eux dans les albums
ont servi c'est quoi notre voix axa
s'est raffiné aussi éclatante
c'est quand même pas de
de savoir que vous avez eue consciemment
intox sur votre le personnage non le
personnage bel outil parce que des fois
on peut penser titre que je demande
comme un chemin quand je suis en jupe
sans jamais se pose des questions parce
que vous êtes des coûts quoi que ce soit
je pense qu'il ya eu des choses commande
ou et carlo 6 2 des fois de son palais
avec un note relationniste de presse pis
il ya des journalistes qui sentait aussi
heurter de se préparer vraiment beaucoup
d'arrivées dans une entrevue qui de
d'avoir juste des responsables surtout
le temps pensé comme je suis un ben qui
rident ses propres johnny
c'est pas tout le monde qui dansent base
le fait que c'est ça il y avait aussi se
le demander non plus comme phil darwin
le cadre d'une entrevue loi y en a deux
montures pas le goût de repartir de là
avec absolument aucun matériel pour
écrire un article je sais comment je
rencontrais trop d'accord c'était drôle
on a un goût de taille menacée mais
c'était bien eu quelques petits trucs
sont annexés comment qu'il faut qu'on il
faut juste qu'on soit à l'écouté un peu
plus des gens comme a pas de cas ce
débat on va parler
[Rires]
4 mais ici dans les pattes en axant son
camarade qui sont passés à des
personnages je pense ok on va être
l'objet jeu c'est possible moi j'aime
croire que c'est vrai comme ça dans la
vie tout un
chacun qui s'est arrêtée de tourner ça
s'arrêtait de tourner enlève ses
lunettes high merci mais non
j'ai tellement déçu
[Rires]
je sais pas quels moyens on veut la
légère cette information le vote lui qui
trône
au
inscrits ça a été aussi sur scène parce
que vous avez aussi changer de direction
d'attitude sur scène non mais
ça c'est plus modulable en fait de si je
dirais même temps ça fait plus partie du
début parce que monet aussi c'est vrai
que sur scène quand c'est juste absurde
à manille il ya un moment de qu'ils font
en
fait un moment qu'ils font dans
une foule puis qu'entrevoir un show
c'est aussi le sentiment que ça connect
pour voler quitter de tout temps
deuxième degré de même
ça fait débat c'est simple j'en ai comme
un moment où c'est quand même un peu
intime et jean j'aimerais savoir c'est
est content d'ouvrir les yeux aux gens
si nice pauvres comme qui tirent au
hasard on a l'impression que personne
d'autre que moi qui peut vu ce moment là
ben ouais ça crise ça des fois ça fait
simple effective c'est sûr que c'est le
fan fait partie d'une vague band ce même
en est aussi ses
dimensions on enlève ce point je parle
aussi pour ouvrir
celle moi je pleure toujours appris à 5e
tour ne l'achetez
mutisme en a parlé à ses deux tonnes 3
tonnes à 20 de son tabouret par là ces
trois minutes et puis c'est comme ça
c'est que c'est sa présentation la
prochaine tonnes c'est juste parler de
son tabouret commun qui compte entre ces
trois tons après
2,0 monde quitte et orgue de ses fans et
ci-dessus ce pack vous avez dix ans et
c'est ça le monde comprenne qui est de
lui que de temps le ti loin possible ça
c'est très naturel infecte immense pour
notre public le besoin de vivre commun
décidé trucks part absurde des fois
comme aimait danser nationale technicien
100g pille on le remerciera pas du genre
en fait c'est vraiment jpy tout le monde
m'est arrivé dans ma main on a vraiment
le monde
le meilleur vin bio la porte est un
super 1600 du frigo de beauty joué avec
jack lemmon jack la racine c'est un
super drogba jeu ghazal in fact et on
peut même il peut même jouer du drame
par un show qui mangent au départ
puisque ses gémissements
chaleur
vous êtes vous êtes ici dans le cadre du
du du festival de la poutine qui s'en
vient ouais
kisangani 23-25
montant d'impôt
ça serait ça serait très punk est juste
pour les gens qui n'ont pas d'emploi
[Rires]
ça fait 15 ans ouais le sait sont plus
aux normes à l'ample suivent les
éditions qu'ils animent mon père d'une
édition à cause de la demi loin
sauf à cames et non du quinzième année
parce qu'on peut compter du 15 ème
édition
ok mais en fait on a une fiche on a subi
on s'est dit
tous ses dires une édition plus ses
dires et 15e édition parce que c'est un
peu comme les hôtels qui ont pas de
13ème étage
dans le film était quand même au 14e -
tu dis pas non pour vraiment au 13e le
monde capote devient pleinement avec le
fils est presque là peut-être que
l'édition dans le fonctionnent que celle
qui est qui a été ce qui paie si la
trêve serait la troisième enfant c'est
exactement comme un autre effectif vous
y avez pensé
si mettons l'idée de faire la 13e
édition est venu dans votre adresse fixe
a conclu et elle existait un idée sera
d'accord plus qu'un idéal aider tout
était fait ah ouais il s'appelle the
supply baroin la programmation est
offert en était tout est élu on pouvait
un jour d'avis
parce que ça on a sûrement de marche
mais ça peut prendre avril que ça a été
un on dit tout les événements sont
annulés pour les nous rendre là on est
rendu à annoncer le festival
fait tout les collaborateurs sont 7 août
et le tout les
festivals organisés dans de l'eau à 100%
d'un bon
d'avoir travaillé comme en un an sur un
truc quelque chose de voir ça se passe
le meti pour nous c'est du temps perdu a
baissé je dirais le gros de trucs en
croque sur gène de cette année le step
un plus par rapport au ban de parole le
festival
c'est un coup le truc c'est le fait
d'affamer t on a dû se faire la musique
l'effectif il ya des mots qui manquent
en scène principale à part avoir perdu
mon temps puis trouver sa place
de pouvoir face avec les amis c'est
vraiment super le fonds d'investissement
c'était comme hot chip et rigoler si
nous on avait aussi c'est notre plus
gros était à vie avec le plus de show
dans le meilleur contexte c'est justin
était un croyant pour les trois accords
tous annulés sable ça peut être pas mal
plus marqué le oisillons du festival qui
étaient comme à
beaucoup beaucoup de travail
soit nous listons c'était vraiment
vraiment pas cool en même temps
l'année d'après on a fait un festival
art cars 2 c'est vraiment restrictif
pandémie ce qui s'était vraiment quand
même assez lourds comme si madoff fait
que vivement les
l'esthétisme première était ici comme un
retour exact seul sait on n'est pas
comme des masses du purell utilisons
pour le monde la distanciation partout
qui est restée comme système s'est
vraiment plan européen 7 062 parce que
les règles changent et tout les droits
toujours qu'on trouve une nouvelle c'est
je pense que c'est les gens qui ont tué
parce que les gens sont rendu compte de
cela n'est pas à celles et ceux qui ont
fini par organiser quelque chose que ça
a été un casse-tête épouvantable pendant
toute l'année parce que il fallait
toujours trouvé une nouvelle manière
de rendre ce possible c'est surtout pour
un match on a fait ce soir comme il ya
beaucoup de revenu au taux générique
c'est comme un truc qui te normalement
on est financièrement quand on sait que
ça marche que ça balance c'est que des
fois j'ai toujours trouvé des nouvelles
manières de
restructurer la faire pour que ça
fonctionne avec les partenaires solides
les gens que tu feras pas bon mais là ok
on aurait bon le finalement on a juste
droit à 1000 personnes mais là qu'ils
m'ont tout est assis ceux des tabourets
puis le comité rappelle de son app store
dire qu'ils ont finalement ils vont être
debout autour d'une table c'est le grand
est en droit d'être debout maintenant
c'est calme sans arrêt des des pilotes
c'est quoi la règle de plomb apple
c'était l'enfant développe en amont
honnêtement qu'ils pouvaient répondre à
nos questions quand il y avait de
nouvelles règles sur tes les cahiers de
charge de sun je peux quand même passé
le menu où le je sais pas il y avait
comme une averse et sortait comme le il
sortait comme la manière n'est pas
prêter tous à minsk c'était quand même
assez final y avait du grillen zotti
pour le studio le souvent on était en
mode j'aime bien aussi de kilteel genre
de commerce peuvent réouvrir plein de
nantes yves gambert c'est nous autres on
fait quoi tu te balades au web est
violent reste ici comme qu'est ce qu'on
voit ce qu'on fait là dedans c'est que
les règles et un plexi à nos potes c'est
cool avec ses vrais bref le progrès le
napperon
n'avons certes un vrai clown apprend des
procédures et sortait c'est comme si ma
nature world in hand existait comme
c'était ça c'est plus dur que l'édition
annulés qui était en fait de prévoir une
édition normale bien passée juste de
l'annuler ce site il est le plus on a eu
la chance par exemple d'avoir vraiment
des collaborateurs exceptionnels c'est
autant dans les agences telles que les
artistes que je boucle sur tous les
agents voulaient vraiment que les trucs
fonctionne on avait plein d'idées ou
modulable avec les artistes stay cool
et longtemps on a fait des versions
notre petit bras de la version 17 ledit
festival comme une âme a finit par
opérer mais aussi le sait toutes les
toutes les commanditaires du festival
c'est qu'ils ont maintenu leur
implication au festival malgré le fait
que ça soit 10 % une édition normale
sauter la plupart des collaborateurs du
festival y ont enregistré juste rester
dans le projet pour ça mais pour cela
n'est pas assez qu'en juillet du monde
qui organisait des événements quand même
qui avait réussi à le faire je pense
qu'il faut que les gens réalisent à quel
point ils ont travaillé fort maintenant
les différentes villes pour que ça se
passait pas de système différent la
stalle à
toutes les entreprises c'est ce qu'avait
dit mon chiot les matons qui participe à
un événement un ton qui allait sur les
mesures si jamais
apprécié commencer autre plan le chef
d'état c'est une tare 9 mai c'est du
mode vente aux
hommes je vécus ici avec steam et on a
lié le booking des dates d'artistes
métro marianne sur ces piles c'est le
back and forth entre les salles de
spectacle et les producteurs se piler
chez dates annulées dates à reporter ses
foulards écharpes
qui ont eu qu'il travaille qui ont mis
qui justement tu construis un gros chat
d'autres cartes ça s'écroule on a refait
un autre moment c'est comme ça est
vraiment aimé ça a été comme ça dans le
théâtre c'était comme ce moment j'ai
classé que tu dois aller même les petits
lits tout le monde s'était sur la
tunique et des bouquets de didier
deschamps au site je pense la gamme des
vins de côtes qui ont la plupart des
festivals à montréal
c'est les artistes internationaux
peuvent rentrer peuvent pas rentrer et
qu'est ce qu'on ferait un prochain at il
vraiment été savamment été dit cela à
tous les niveaux pour tout le monde mais
selon arrive en 2022 avec avec une
édition complète bien
alors on est proche
mais là
ça fait 15 ans fait est ce que c'est
vous qui est artiste à la piscine comme
ça que quand c'est ce que l'aja n'en
existe pas le fesf à la piscine ça
commençait avec des discussions
nationales quand on roule beaucoup en
automne dans la vie le salage projet
alors j'avais le temps centralise il
exact
c'est des discussions traque confondrait
faire un festival
exactement par là ya longtemps par la
revenante chaud le steak à ma joie
checker combien ça coûte et je vis mon
ti qui joue à paris la ville voici une
ouverture vis ma dignité le pied dedans
ce camp qui vont mère de l'artiste ça
coûte ça coûte combien engagé et fidèle
à la sécurité la patente passé commun et
dans le guide bat
le meeting et légaux ont fait ce
vraiment si c'est vraiment ce qu'on fait
on l'a jamais eue c'est ça comme une
lente évolution inverse hautmont
préannonce hôtels d'amman
on me l'avait dit on le fait les aigles
jamais eu d'accord qui légua sa voix et
un style afin de reprendre du temps ça
va être
probablement perdre de l'argent
n'a jamais eu comme le meeting comme qui
dit oui qui dit non tu sais on est juste
comme tranquillement et louis-paul est
là est-ce que vous avez aimé ton est ce
que vous êtes déjà assisté avec des
chiffres d'en face eu ça s'est aussi
fait un peu genre ah non ce sous sol oui
absolument parce que ce monde se soit
son background
5 500 go qui monte tout un économisme
moi c'est ce médecin c'est vrai que
rapidement un enfant si l'idée c'est d'y
ben samassa ce petit ami sa démission
j'ai regardé comment ça s'équilibre id
tech je sais j'ai commencé à monter un
budget
clément est jetée comme bon mais je
pense la vitre qui sont impliqués il
faut que georges
écrire à la ville je me suis trouvé un
prolongement vraiment rapidement qu'un
meeting avec le conseil de la ville
ça a évolué de même plus c'est quand
même bien et la ville serait partante
face
nous avons commanditaires de biens
qui lui vaut
la batterie
c'était comme une lente évolution métier
pendre au nez des
godillots d'achat font énormément nos
enfants sont bien fait se fixer ces
camps par josé si on avait décidé de
partir au restaurant
l'ouverture ça l'était fucking blue qui
suit un point qu elle mais quand tu
écoutes info puis c'est par là dedans tu
puisses et
l'entrepreneuriat c'est beaucoup de
beaucoup de ses rapides on a on est
heureusement on n'a pas fait d'erreurs
graves
mais on a fait des erreurs absolument
banane et n'avait pas prévu c'est
une capacité d'accueil de 5000 personnes
par an
surtout quand la culture de la ville à
cette époque le stand culture de nous on
connaît l'artiste principal mais les
premières parties mais moi j'étais on
n'arrive pas à enlever même pas pour les
voir exactes aux qu' énormément changé
maintenant festival c'est 6 au 10 12 mai
personnes qui se présentent sur le site
ils vont se présenter au ces de manière
pratiquement continu pendant toute la
soirée ce qu'on n'avait pas prévu
nostalgie qu'on avait une capacité
d'accueil mais la capacité de faire
payer les gens pour les faire entrer
dans le festival on l'avait calculé sur
longtemps mais quand on perd on se
présente en 15 minutes pendant que 5000
personnes en quinze minutes les machines
à québec a pas de face et ja à ce jour
c'est comme
dire une erreur anticipation derrière de
manière de gérer la billetterie puis
l'argent aussi par rapport à ce facteur
grosse erreur par rapport la
restauration les baous s'il y avait des
trucs qui fonctionnait c'est plus ou
moins bien mais au niveau de la sécurité
des territoires attitude c'était correct
et il n'y a pas eu de gens blessés une
monde qui ont passé vraiment mauvaise
soirée mais assurément le stade ouali
festival de l'année le religieux était
sans jo qui est beaucoup de gens qu'en
fait c'est la file genre pour
heureusement 40 ans d'une heure et quart
avant d'entrer
je la classerais accès comme moi j'ai
toujours trouvé que les gens et on était
vraiment intelligent avec nous à préty
de revenir à l'après midi allez on vous
redonne une chance on disait long on a
réparé ces on va être créée cette année
petit les gens à découvrir de revenir
ici même quand ça se passe et les gens
quand même été cool mais je suis mené
s'était rendu au point où j'en il y
avait une file pour la piscine dont donc
pas ceux qui ont donné des bières au
monde pour comme
des lesbiennes
[Rires]
chantant des trois accords il portait
une
burka maja patente
c'est vrai que c'est comme si on disait
des trucs bien résumé genre c'est la
première année je me suis pris t on est
comme on se dit ma commune je peux
27 $ en prix pour un soir mais des sites
donnant les jambes et en argent un
pilonne instant l'est encore il ya des
gens n'arrêtent pas de
donner enfin il faut que cela donne 1 2
point noir fait que ça prend maintenant
qu'il ya 2005 mais ça vient tout seul
plus le monde qui disent mon genre de ne
même pas été assez intelligent pour un
peu un pli ou c'est arriverons là c'est
34 ça prend toutes les échelles de
visualiser toutes les claires je me suis
entouré par tous en vivre s'y trouvait
de change tellement bien rendus
et ont vidé les commerces locaux de 1
dollar là deux pièces c'était comme
faire avancer toutes les fonds
nécessaires à ce que le festival se
passe le foot dépose tout cet argent
ouattara compte mail personnes
débarquées devant ethias sa faute contre
la petite machine que les vendeurs de
drogue
cedeno a mis le cd copé un nouveau
ton ami de drummondville condé 20 pièces
déposées sur
des affaires de
l'année deux
ratios d'erreur
de manière fracassante c'est
impressionnant à quel point mais même à
cinq organisateurs
ce conte échappée loin dit que ça a été
long le mettons mais même encore dit je
me dis [ __ ] chaque année en dessous et
qui ne tombe pas dire quelque chose
qu'on n'a pas prévu
c'est comme si mais là les premières
années c'est impressionnant le nombre de
choses que tu oublies six ans et moi je
trouvais que
ces femmes qui sont infinies
variable puis vous aviez tout jamais
facile de vivre a fait rapatrier un
genre d d'experts
consultants north bien non mais vu qu'on
fait beaucoup de festivals aussi comme
un musicien juste le fait d'observer
chaque événement ou voir ce qui marche
bien qu'est ce qui m'arrive pamiers
c'est se passer d'une bonne manière de
s'améliorer dans vis de ces de prendre
une décision puis d'analyser les erreurs
que tu fais ce que les autres ne jouent
sur un feedback par année c'est comme tu
peux prévoir toute l'année pensait tous
que toujours pensé que tu es bon lorsque
tu es peut-être plus tard et au festival
le theux la seule manière de corriger
ces l'année d'après nous on a eu 15
répétition présentement sauf que le fait
de voir les autres festivals le tiche
peut voir maintenant des trucs que moi
j'ai prévu fait cher non ça c'est d'la
marde cellule ni d'un accueillir des
artistes comme ça marche pas ça que je
vois les limites ce domaine à la fac on
a la chance d'être de faire de
l'espionnage industriel maintenu dans la
plupart des trucs particules à timmins
dans la manière que les salles de
spectacles accueille les artistes en
europe par exemple celle là énormément
influencé le manager du monde félicité
lequel il s'est fait doubler par avec
entrain
aux artistes
le spectacle
de bouteilles d'eau juste un accent
personnes sur place
des techniciens sont l'autre pu se fait
six heures que sont lyon il y en à boire
et à manger quand il était dans une
salle de 1200 personnes au québec c'est
dans une salle de 150 personnes en
france
il ya six personnes qui t'accueille un
chef il ya type sont comme ils sont
dotés de la bouffe pour tout le monde
les textes ont lu des textes qui vide le
trois cadres haut placés
de manière
extrêmement bien cueillir banalité
c'est ce qu'on arrive maintenant le
festival des portes au québec permettant
à tout un moment dans journée nous
mettons alexis comme rendu au bar de
l'événement pose des questions posées
question et comme à
chaque fois festive et fax au cours
desquels des erreurs on a fait moins on
appris de nos erreurs m'ont aussi appris
énormément inspirant les autres même les
big baby walz et comme je mentais à
chicago les plis franco le jazz
juste le fait d'aller voir si c'est le
mal aussi convaincu c'est que ceux-ci
cool so chic où l'artiste c'est cool
mais on le budget festival on laisse
notre festival juste pour
mais quand même philosophie générale la
patente qui nous influencent elles
mêmes ces gros festivals le choc et qui
font un post mortem mortem après chaque
fois qu'ils sachent et c'est ce week end
à la piscine qui savent donner des
biarrots monde qui attendent ma poutine
c'est bon c'est pas et puis c'est un
fait de l'attachement
aussi piquante et un festival salive à
lui fait qu'un
nouvel saint exemple nous en faisons a
ajouté me sign et le mon premier
conscience et il va avoir une zone où ça
bleed leçon à 110 ou les le gros stage
va péter dans l'autre tijd fait qu' on
essaie de prévoir au maximum
comment éviter ce problème en première
partie premièrement avec des techniciens
exceptionnels qui sont capables de
moduler toute l'équipe de son pot pour
que ça ce serait le moyen n'est pas que
possible mais aussi des physiquement le
tir séquestrer les deux glaces
aux mairies d'ici à 2019 je trouve
exalead est pas mal d'après ce qu'on
voit sur un site où il ya deux semaines
je vois marché entre les 2 5 puis je
vois que c'est le chaos partout
on parle encore de chez à gauche eag
s'applique partout leur marché je dois
titre une cinquante ans l'autre l'autre
50 ans l'autre il ya aussi de ses
commandes au niveau lui pour avoir un
peu de laisser-aller c'est bon il ya la
perfection des espacements partait pour
35000 personnes en une fin de semaine
des affaires kung fu chi c'est quoi la
priorité que les gens soient en sécurité
c'est qu'il ya 15 ans good time puis qui
attendent pas trop long terme placer les
gens aussi on a fait ça que c'est un
flottement il faut assimilation c'est le
chaos ça se peut qu'un parole à quelque
part mais qui pour gérard pièce effet il
ya peu de soul un peu de jerry ce qu'on
est capable on peut faire un petit os x
et iphone tout en avant de là il ya
beaucoup de variables incontrôlable la
température
justement non alors on bien que
justement dans le cahier des choses
qu'on a déjà véhicule c'est
comme en cinq ans la capitale ou tel
truc mais j'ai des fois que technique
est ce que vous vous souvenez du du line
up du premier festival quand meme
je sui amérique là pour une ivg que
lapointe je pense que lost fingers je
pense qu'il y avait
longtemps attendu
savez savez blow up dans cette étendue
il y avait
non parce qu'à ce stade
après avec daniel bélanger c'est un peu
comme genre au micro ondes ou des trucs
et omnikrom
regarde mais c'est
moi je me suis dit bonjour dans ce sens
et ça c'était la première année deux
jours je me suis aguerri que la pointe
ça m'avait marqué pas ce qui tend à voir
qui s'inquiétait vraiment je suis pas
déchaîné
mouillé sous la pluie c'est bien bien
sûr la tire en premier festival le
premier soir il ya de la pluie avec le
e-billet m'en plaignais tant pis
si vous vous ennuyez mois si oui mais il
était fidèle bien ça a pas
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
aidé par
noah fax est s et es saha était cool
quand c'est sorti mais ces gens
d'affaires je te demande si tu mens
festival premier soit immiscé comme
partout la puis les autres la décision
pensé à demander le ça a été une
évidence aux autres comment qui au début
on voulait le faire à victoriaville on
commence à faire des recherches ou venez
le fictionnel si c'est ça ma prochaine
question c'est à dire tout flamme
on y est on est né à drummondville les
gays y vivent encore le fait que ce qui
avait pu se passer si on avait joué
partout au québec en 2007 littéralement
dans toutes les villes sauf deux romans
nouvelles demandes c'est comme ça
pourrait être cool kai un festival de
musique à la demande je sais qu'à
80 d'habitants dans l'es10 marines
qu'est ce que j'écoute les trois bières
belges de plus à des caches qui me plaît
et je le ferai car ça c'est que jean
pierre mais je peux dire qu'en quatre
festivals exact factice tkm pourquoi
gatineau pourquoi de sherbrooke 3 vias
dans ce registre là victoriaville aussi
on avait
quand on a grandi à caen était plus
jeune andreu même si je me souviens
qu'on avait largement d'aller voir des
shows des messieurs mais il y avait pas
eu et il y avait du monde hier les
cultures qui faisait si c'était comme un
jeu d'enfant les gens et halim c'était
quand même pas de la musique populaire
sans main dont l'allergie ans par
exemple d'être en grande ville du québec
puis la scène punk était tellement forte
à montréal puis québec que la plupart
des bars et à drummondville comme dans
sa loge imagine qu'il se dit ce
garçon sho utilise dans ses hôtels gaz
sinon vos paniers laporte qui ont
continué à très l'effectif faisait comme
le spectrum à montréal puis l'impérial à
québec puis ils y arrêtaient faire un
show dans une salle communautaire
dramane en passant si nous enlevons ses
shows de fait qui me choquait auquel on
avait assisté carrément des des chaudes
sous sol d'église n'y avait eu une coupe
de
une coupe d'arrêt de tourner maintenant
il ya dans ce temps les y avait comme
les colocs je me suis tu es venu d'une
main et il y avait eu comme un genre de
festival mais c'était comme un soir il
monteyne la grande scène c'était d'y
arriver une fois appréciée rue jean
leloup jean trois ans plus tard c'est
arrivé comme jamais cette époque n'était
pas régulier tout ça que quand il vit
une fois que bruxelles avait appris en a
peu ça récemment quitté comme genre
d'étudiants qui est vraiment rien dans
la drôme en
vérité comme comme quand événements dans
le mondial de la culture festival de
folklore puis sauf que ces points pour
décider d'où de 14 à les voir l'ukraine
dans ses passes et la lituanie de souci
parce que vous le valez
marché dans les sentiers tôt cet homme
est le boss ont été clairement pas le
public cible de sun vous combien de fois
vous l'avez fait en tant que groupe
trois fois trois fois la dernière foire
de la 10e édition
fait que ça paye ça fait 5 et 6 vous
n'avez pas joué cinq ans
contre six en compétition grand largue
le stress auquel ouais mais non c'est
s'engagent souvent qu'on engagerait un
artiste il fallait le tronçon correspond
maintenant cesser notre programmation
qui tue même des fois donc simon n'est
pas d'accord sur ce qu'on devrait
s'engager pour mieux connaître l'année
prochaine nouvel album comment la
musique en m'engageant tout en
charge le plein prix là on
s'engage à peu près aussi souvent qu'on
en compte engager comme les cowboys
fringants
ouais je pense qu'une réflexion 6eme ton
avec les années maintenant comme ben en
fait ça tombait comme ça aussi ça a
donné le même mais si on avait joué pour
le 10e c'est quand même si c'est déjà
long moment dit bon mais là c'est
important pythie le festival c'est
tellement une histoire de toute une
communauté qui se rassemble tout le
monde qui met du sien est ce que ça fait
un événement que sa fin ça fait un
moment quand même que quand je te mentir
par un jalon de même comme le 10e 15e
ben c'est cool pour ouvrir de comptes
joue c'est comme un certain moment on
profite de ce moment là pour retrouver
connecter que le monde puis saint jean
de de remerciement le site est aussi
l'axé cool si je pense que cet aspect là
aussi maintenant qui comme quasiment
symbolique très bruyant c'est pertinent
qu'on joue non seulement pour non
seulement au niveau du cycle musical
mais en plus c'est symboliquement d'être
est-ce que j'en viens à vous en tant que
ben la méthode est ce que commencent à
évoluer avec les années mais ton
but croate est ce qu est ce que vous
sentez
renouvellement qui tout à de nouvelles
personnes qui découvrent les trois ans
moi je me souviens je pense à marc
marquez qui est générique aux dégâts
chez début vingtaine kimouche j'avais
écouté les trois accords je peux encore
d'accord mais si j'avais écouté il
déclare être d'accord que ça avait sorti
puis j'avais justement 12 ans qu'il est
les petits kits de 12 ans qui enseignait
il m'arrive pizza à prendre bambou
parfaitement moulée ft com qu'est ce
qu'il ya vraiment un passage de flambeau
d'une nouvelle génération qui des
combats on le voit on voit dans les
shows si
c'est comme si
je veux maintenant il ya des gens qui
vient de voir les trois accords
qui sont rencontrés dans un show des
trois accords qui ont un enfant qu'un
large 2003 d'accord taxicom peut-être
des coupes de 40,2 en 40 ans qui sont
rencontrés à la fin de l'université qui
ont aujourd'hui eu un enfant qui amène à
13 ans qui vient de voir le chou avec
c'est vraiment spécial pour rire d'eux
comme cette aprilia ça il ya
ce soit avec les
trucs sont connectés il y en a qui vient
de
nous découvrir aujourd'hui fait je sais
pas mais c'est
réellement
un constat renouvellement du scrutin
puis même on fait encore à ce jour du
parti universitaire
éviter quand même voulu faire partie de
l'upm dans notre chapiteau comme chez
vous via les ont versé 3 yann verser la
vase comme un pôle universitaire coup
cette fois l'adversaire
sont là pour moi la meilleure on n'a pas
assez de ses coûts la partie d'une
verster 11 jours on reste là bas on fait
parler tout le monde c'est vrai qu'il
coule à la rippe c'est absolument
inapproprié pour nous d'être quittée il
ya les bordés bien un parking lot
enfin
pillon et 20 ans commente encore ses
coûts mais ça c'est déjà beaucoup mais
pas
[Rires]
chez vous pas trop tard
c'est nike a mis du temps à cet effet
c'est comme je pense depuis presque le
début en fait qu'il est il toujours eu
cette là cette largeur de spectre d'un
étang des grands-parents cette section
le piquet qui trouve août est justement
se trouvent les joggeurs ou ceux qui
disent comme tout est
c'est ce volet là je suis pas fier de ce
qu'on est qu'on est des gens de tous les
âges qui souhaite que ses coups que
c'est que ça continue aussi c'est après
ceux ci comme ça devient plus en dehors
qu'est-ce qui justement qu'est-ce qui
accroche pour pour les générations qui
suivent les lire mais jamais autant de
monde d'un show c'est la bonne nouvelle
je parle pas je déjoue les trois accords
par des choix en général les
festivaliers jamais autant de festivals
au québec les artistes n'ont jamais
vendu autant psychiatre dans les salles
c'est comme les québécois ils vont voir
des shows présentement d'artistes
québécois en masse beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup c'est impressionnant la fin de
rencontre mais aussi des chansons le
schème est faux c'est vraiment envie aux
proches de tous il ya tellement de
d'artistes de la relève qui sont qui
sont tellement bons jours jusqu'à ce que
je voudrais c'est nous aussi des fois on
est surpris de jouer avec missan
d'actionnaires ce que j'ai eu avec nous
autres et comme civil moche pitt
dentelle tuncay comme je t'ai com - il
ya le retour du match vraiment rétablie
il bat le noir il fait des choses de ce
genre et puis pour des faits
d'alcoolisme et à des marchés d'un trou
de rat je trouve qu'il est chaude qu'a
réagi comme il ya comme une culture de
ceux qui s'installent liquide m se
passait vraiment une femme n'est pas
évident quand ça brasse
les artistes voit ça dans d'autres
choses dans leur show il ya c'est de
faire en sorte que ça se passe encore
plus vrai que comme un phénomène
d'emballement ou présentement
ces genres l'énergie est incroyable
c'est vraiment aux temps chauds des
cowboys fringants nous et bat le noir
fou qui n'importe quoi puisque bordel
dans le till un fax et c'est vraiment
cool aussi d'avoir cette énergie là même
dans une musique qui est pas
nécessairement appelé à se le dise on
n'est pas un show d'exodus là
comme des trois accords oui mais oui
puis ouais mais
vraiment puis on est vraiment dans une
forme justement que les chaussons son
lit je
voudrais que les puits
mamba team et on pourrait les la relève
est aussi un hub à qui david carr un
choc était complètement mongols c'est ce
qui va qui les lie aux anges on essaie
vraiment de cinq centres centre influent
ce qui fait que montrer pousse à faire
le show le plus banal nos jours savage
aussi d'aller bouquet elle ou adrian
soirée que vous ôter son shoot
incroyable où adrian qui a commencé sa
carrière de manière c'est comme c'était
super amoled super sat avoir chaussé
comme chez toi qui le lie à la violence
cool
je pense qu'il ya eu ce sens un joke
c'est un bon exemple sans doute mais le
drian il ya beaucoup d'artistes je
trouve qu'ils ont comme
quand sont arrivés à la conclusion que
c'est le fonctionnement quand ça brasse
ans excellent c'est cette énergie les
elfes en aller chercher qui ont modifié
leur approche vraiment d'olhain de la
musique sur l'album
un premier album qui un peu molle aux
guitares au dessus deuxième album c'est
gentil nvidia qui pinsky deux tiers
cette souffrance ont fait deux trois
festivals où il sentait que leur
matériel peut-être gauche lo qui cache
etc
smoot pour un festival estival et le
changement de cap l'argent qu'ils
mangent luc michaud salue tout mais
je sais où les arrangements live team et
on me met batum préféré prendre et loire
c'est et recel mais genre qui tue quand
même ce maudit l'album puis en chaussée
comme complément mongols
ces autres dissidents dans toutes leurs
suppôts des feuilles puis ce genre de
choses là où est ce que la musique peut
être consommée vraiment juste en audio
puis en jeu sans quémander fois une
musique de background de prendre le
tournant du rock et de la musique c'est
fait pour qu'on la joue depuis qu'on les
côtes tout le monde ensemble contribuent
tout le monde ensemble le but de revenir
là je trouve ça vraiment ouais je truc
je me demandais même en est on on a
souvent dit que de s'acheter comme
messam etc et enfin l'album j'ai envie
de conquête c'est que tout arrache les
gens avec ce soit calmes qu'à brasser
je trouve qu'il ya pas y'a pas beaucoup
pendant un moment j'étais quand même pas
beaucoup d'affaires qui brassent tant
que puits plus est comme ses services ça
se passe mais c'est exaltant je pense
aussi peut-être qu'en ce moment le monde
avec thé avec la pandémie puis le fait
qu'il n'y avait pas de show le monde il
réalise c'est le fun un peuple à la
catharsis des shows de sortir de ces
mots justes à lille on le sait sur qui
on sent quand même de l'autre bord mais
j'étais allé voir agent de machines
c'est plaines d'abraham piger j'ai
jamais vu les plaines comme ceux ci
j'allais vivre en bretagne j'ai lutté
mais j'ai jamais vu les plaines comme
ceux où est-ce que même dans côte en
arrière le monde dont deux doigts d
impôts qu avons nous été ternie justice
vient d'engager matin il devait avoir à
peu près 50 matchs il s'est plaint
d'abraham mais je te d'en acheter
acheter en avance on avance
avec leurs vols il y avait deux mois je
pète à côté de moi ça brassait monde
c'est long très clairement non quand
vraiment vide en ressentir ça brasse
d'un choc doit nous sommes 3 6 euros
pour ta santé loi
c'est vraiment un coup mais aussi avec
les années les organisateurs les
promoteurs puis la sécurité ont su
comment gérer ça c'est ont su comment
approcher ceux au sein de citi je me
rappelle du web acte qui veut des mois
que le tea party labellisé la sécurité
car avec les écoutes dans le dos des
guides pour l'imitateur et ont compris
que c'est commun c'est je peux
comprendre certains festivals qui dit qu
elle paye de crowd sur le film des trucs
comme ça c'est si leur compte sur la fin
mettez avoir déclenché pendant tout le
festival devrait attirer des trucs sont
sécuritaires vendredi puis aussi
même nouveau festival a personnellement
donné on faisait
des glasgow rangers puis je voyais des
jeunes familles dans ce qui est
peut-être dans plein milieu
car la sécu gens vous juste allé leur
dire que je pense pas qu'ils réalisent
que c'est de
savoir vol en estie que
je pense que les gens ont un oeil pour
essayer de faire en sorte que ça se
passe
réputé mois mais tant que tu te quartier
des
mots de mon frère on est tout le temps
malgré l'intensité qui avait le qui est
le dieu aussi
franchement les autres tombent dans le
moche pitt est pas loin car quittera les
ranger ta question expérience j'étais à
12h et de la semaine passée et puis j'ai
justement eu un phénomène de wolof dette
quelle bonne opportunité pour me rendre
jusqu'à la clôture en avance je préfère
je serais déjà atteint à la clôture en
avant qu'il s'agisse fermé en arrière de
moi
on va passer une coupe en avant pis je
voyage souvent la même fraternité le
même genre de de solidarité qu'il y
avait moi j'ai toujours aimé être dans
ces environnements le centre qui me
nourrit boukoubi
s'est-il classique ce n'est que perdu ou
la casquette ou t la sécurité fait juste
pointer en arrière de toi pour ta de
bien d'autres qui borissov qui va de
l'inde et ça maintenant nous seconde
c'est au dessus ces sites code le qui
sont vraiment natif de son environnement
la de choses comme si le bordel c'est
550 personnes qui se rentrent dedans ça
va jamais mal un tel geste comme
genre un chose qui m'ont désaxée juste
plein de monde cherche les gueux qui
perdure c'est toi le rend bien mon
épaule est une contrainte ça recommence
à arrêter ce genre
ne regorge pas hollande qui était pris
dans la
jambe ou complément une gens d'apple en
plastique jetés comme toutes ces
quotidiens anglophones chez quantic
qu'est ce qui se passe et que j'emmène
tout un joueur de rugby je me suis pété
et ciel je me souhaite opérer comme
cette semaine ses fils ses fils et ses
amis des activités comme
[Musique]
le québec a mis sa main sur le truc
comme amel au bar du poignet sa chaise
roulante en arial cia comme fait un
petit cocon be c'est le 5 6 tonnes
n'est pas mon
truc est vivre pas dans la vie autrement
que dans des environnements absolument
chaotique comme ça mais non moi je peux
comprendre que le grand retour je le
comprends je la lis énormément une
énergie qui est vraiment vraiment cool
dit les gens qui comprennent pas ce
qu'ils veulent pas lui c'est super
facile pour vous de l'éviter c'est
vraiment facile
[Musique]
c'est drôle ce qui est et ce qu'elle
crée en est quitte plus ses commanderies
qu'à cliquer cette phase clé que liquide
qui se sont rendus alors j'ai d'abord
dit ben
ça permet sur tric parce que et c'est ce
que tu dis le puck par tim tebow clegg
se tiendra dans préféré présentement
il ya plein de trucs vraiment vraiment
vraiment cool qui se passe présentement
mais aussi les vieux pont qui tourne à
800 emplois ces gens ça existe encore
noté
je pense honnêtement je le prends comme
toujours été vraiment fort qu'avec le
point emploi comme celui je pense barre
le jeune fille tirage pourrait faire des
choses françois frères comme des tournis
perpétuelle au québec tout indique billy
talent des comores un éternel et je
pense que billy talent et je pense
qu'ils font d'eux deux ou trois
festivals changements cet été ici les
gens à chaque été j'ai fait la sens
trente deux jusqu'à jusque dans le
bas-du-fleuve de québec chuq et dans le
bas du fleuve puis j'ai passé deux
villes où est ce qu'il y avait une
affiche de genre billy talent
[Rires]
nous devons écouter nexity marie-mai la
vente qui j'en écoutais les premiers
premier album charmant dans les albums
fred st-gelais ouais c'est cette idée
début 2010 était qu une crise c'est ce
genre ça sonne plus actuelle ces
personnes comme aujourd'hui comme
rammstein
mais il y avait un côté effectivement
pas pendant lé pa ys et laissait les
rifains celle ci les riffs qui qui qui
font que ça trotte évidemment les
premiers albums mal mais
vous autres métaux en attaque ben c'est
quoi que
votre attitude
c'est ce que c'est comme au début est ce
que maintenant vous êtes plus relax avec
ceux qui en feront la loi comprend
l'album c'est que c'est quoi le saas est
strictement fait pas mal de l'abonnement
3 1 comme son seul l'imposer sans
vouloir l'imposer je pense que mon nez
il ya quand même six essais on s'est
vraiment rendu compte au fil du temps
que quand sort l'album est comme
inception demandé aussi je trouve que
c'est ces coûts le sortir des affaires
et je
pense que mon ami il ya
toujours le phénomène où tu peux
attendre si j'avais un diction as-tu que
pierre flynn ouais
ouais bîmes vera et demi j'attends
d'avoir assez à cette chanson je trouve
qu'ils ont
jetés comme ses coûts mais genre le
résultat c'est qu'il fait pas souvent
les albums thé sadies vraiment précieux
que en fait mais je sais pas mais je
pense que pour nous je trouve ça plus
fan de 2 pouces un prêt à machine de
hockey mais on ne sait pas ce poème en
album en trois ans c'est comme
c'est comme étant un album par jour
mais moi je trouve ça cool comme ça ça
fait une régularité aussi de la
production de pie xi de voir on ait eu
comme but est de montrer tes ou le
pigeant dans
cette phase à ce moment ci fait que ce
que vous avez accessoires et même pas
mal en ligne et je parle du pardon venu
comme berne basculer les membres du ben
vous avez toujours été pas mal en ligne
et / ou est ce que vous étiez où est ce
que vous étiez rendue quand même si vous
voulez en vouliez aller vite mais si
c'est ça c'est ça se définit dans le
dans les discussions qui précède l'album
c'est à dire que d'habitude mettons fin
de tournée survient à un moment
d'accalmie un peu on prend une pause que
je suis un peu de temps d'écrire le bain
il les discussions commencent avec ghost
notes pigasse bango qui nous album puis
souvent on s'envoie la balle de campuac
légaux aussi que manger que tel truc
soutient on dans les communs puis
avec gosse des fausses idées de ce que
j'avais en tête de com qu'est-ce qui
fait triper de faire la même pile ben ça
se peaufine au fil du temps mais c'est
après ce très beau prévoir mais kantari
en studio dès fois ci c'est potenti tu
peux pas dire qu'ils ont fait l'album
qui va être dans ce style petit
évidemment c'est quand même plus c'est
quoi les tout-petits
enjoint les toons que tu te découvres
pris le dessus en mettant ce qu'on sait
qu'on a envie de sucré le wok et
finalement on a un album qui qui dans
cette direction là mais c'est justement
pas prémédité une tournée france l'autre
la réalisation d'une toune peinture pure
celle de l'autre accès dont on
n'arrivait pas que ddd ref des
références claires du genre ok tels
toulouse mettons j'entends la faire mais
oui absolument mais dans les tournois
ouais ouais mais c'est souvent c'est
dans le processus c'est comme à la guy
tandis que ça marche pour la team étant
l'acteur alec satisfait un truc un peu
plus tôt c'était le genre mettant ce
serait un truc c'est
kittel berne frère maintenant c'est ton
test demain imprimantes avec deux
systèmes acquiescé au final ça paraît
moins parce que quand tu écoutes
l'ensemble ça ressemble juste parce
qu'on a fait le sait ça s'en ressent
bien seulement 1 une influence précise
mais mes yeux ce processus ne paraît
dans le dans l'autre il faut c'est
vraiment l'on sait on trouvait les
directions la météo venait aussi qu'il
était c'est sûr que faire 3 1 c'est de
faire un album ou 3 1 c'est vrai fan
pour un même c'est comme comme nous avec
le genre et public ont un prix l'idylle
est le genre de sale [ __ ] festival
confessé c'est aussi ça sert aussi
beaucoup de ces bassins comme le ce qui
naturellement on faire un enfin des
salons fardeau supplémentaire on va
faire une tournée de festivals sont vous
faites tout lié au jazz festival enfin
nouvel album qui ont parlé d'un truc là
qui est comme quelque chose qui vraiment
comme naturelle là dedans ou si on
faisait pas ça si on faisait comme un
album aux cinq armes à reims l2 infracom
ce que je vois un parti indépendant
autre chose à faire mais c'est comme un
sweet spot on dirait le troisième parce
que pour 1000 cours des fouets ce
site ou match sur un piteux tête un
autre que moi ça m'embête c'est avec
beaucoup de peine que j'ai aimés puis
que j'ai quand même perdu de vue je ne
met pas dans le catalogue
ccgt éléments matériels qu'il était
c'est même plus quoi écouter le telle
attente devient tellement grande comme
ces mots shooter c'est comme kendrick
lamar ça a été très loin c'est ce soin
je sais qu'à
laisser agresser attendant que ça va
être insel finalement c'est comme un
gros virage assez bon mais je sais
vraiment pas ce aussi bon que je
m'attendais à 10 fois ça qu'ils ont un
peu trop d'attentes aux citoyens c'est
un peu trop long ce qui l'attend ou même
sacré juste comme qui prends mais tu
sais tout ça fait qu'il ya nulle sur
l'album qui ont fait des années qu'ils
sont pleins d'eau que des fois tu y es
l'instat hérité de george est un des
pays etc mettons-les l'air du temps
l'environnement inspire de quoi
toutefois le sortir plus vite qu'un
battre le fer pendant qu'il est chaud
c'est il faut une sortie des enfants a
vraiment plus tard c'est comme andré
quel contexte ipu
ce qu'était le regard d'un artiste comme
charlotte cardin sortie des cinq groupes
dépendant fokine
avançons à leur guise à l'album
sont exacts
l'actualité oui on en était toute à la
joie c'est comme l'album et d'europe et
qui tout le monde est ok on va écouter
l'album de charles k o
mais je pense après ça il n'y a pas de
cadre à cette il n'y a pas de manière
c'est ce qui marche pour un mot persan
marché pour l'autre c est des gens qui
sont super prolifique c'est cela sa
définition font quasiment c'est la caste
accès lipton sont bonnes
y en a qui sortent un album à toutes les
années de 7,8 en nous ou dix ans t&d
banton faisait bon exercice
c'est sûr que c'est un peu le sien cette
impression de déception la preuve après
cinq ans le temps commence à faire mal
ouais est ce que on pose cette question
là pas mal tous les musiciens qui
viennent s'il est ce que puis peut-être
que ça c'est le changer au courant de ma
carrière mais ce qu'une tournée et trois
accords c'est rock dans le backstage
vous avez vécu votre ça dépend pour qui
tu sais c'est sûr que pour quelqu'un qui
sait sa journée c'est
des cqp de ces enfants c'est travailler
9 à 5 c'est très rare jeudi soir dans un
5 à 7
le coucher un exempt ce soir qu'une
soirée avec nous ils vont trouver ce
vraiment est en hausse le 6 mai pour
maigrir gueuse plus exact on n'est pas
si longtemps
on peut libyens ont fait la fête avec
n'ont
[Rires]
jamais
fait de pau dans ce genre devraient
condamner
[Rires]
cependant fait pas de pause on m'a donné
tant chez le baudet bien quand même ce m
c'est faire des bonds choqué tant chez
france est commun mais non comme je dis
je pense qu'on est dans la moyenne d'un
de des gens de notre âge qui font de la
musique pour ce faire la fête le temps
n'y a pas de personne à
personne et inquiets pour nous
si on n'a pas de l'air si on n'a pas de
l'art des jardins qu'ils échappent
mais c'est comme si
pendant trois
coups sûrs ce que je fous
là la question on se couche sur couche
parce qu'un terrain de questions la
terre et du coup je pense qu'ils les
plis cowboys fringants son de cloche
gitana xi e
pour les autres j'ai tourné avec des
fossés casse
et des autres sont une cage tout allait
fournir commun comment vous êtes reçus
en europe puis est ce que ça a changé
ça pas tant changé je dirais on est
vraiment vu comme un label à l'image du
benz a toujours été très punk commun ue
ils ont associé ce
rapidement vin très
alternatif c'est ce qu'on n'a pas vécu
ici parce que le
fait de ta la radio sud de
moi c'est ce que les gens ici une
constat je pense que même bain juste de
musique et
je m'en fous là bon il ya vraiment une
perception questin comme comptant bien
de pain qui est comme ça toute cette
vague bleue qui paraît qu'on arrive là
bas ça ferait dans le public et lui ben
ouais parce que c'est si c'est si on
parlait de manche peut tantôt mais la
boïenne
csn chute de sa personne c'est moi je
dis à personne c'est justement ce
mannequin ici c'était vraiment pas sur
la vague des prêts de 10 12 ans festival
si nous autres les gens ont toujours
sauter ont toujours dansé beaucoup le
métier vraiment comme fuck islam
la bosse déjà auch est le tpiy pas
vraiment ces cubains d affronter des
fois le dessert un peu plus du tout sur
une péniche à lyon non prévus pour faire
bouger
[Rires]
la vibe la bcc l'avancé pour comprendre
que c'est un organe non faire des saltos
enfin des salles à paris de 4000
personnes
millions de ça va bien lausanne
d'autres villes sont que sept comme du 2
3 1 300 personnes fait que c'est
vraiment vraiment super super cool
mais c'est drôle de penser de voir que
les perceptions sont différentes ne fait
pas de télé labo un plus grand accès aux
factures les gens ils nous ont connus
dans des radios quand même pu attendre
de voir le collégial universitaire
sinon c'est le bouche à oreille faction
billon signaux millions sont rentrés
dans les trois accords avec un angle
très
content d'aller chercher ce stage en
république la fac c'est canteloup dans
ses salles les gens et de trois amis ils
reviennent année après année de se fixer
sur glace comme dans ce circuit la de
juste du monde qui disent ce qu'ils ont
à peu près tout en jetant un pétard mais
les gens sont plus jamais mais je pense
que la bei avait quelque chose de très
quand les gens sont plus conscients de
la dimension absurde du groupe nous ça
m'avait frappé c'est au début parce que
ici les gens font des fois je commençais
à qui est-il d'humour dans vos tonnes là
bas c'est quand même c'est quand même
fait de l'absurde gens qui savent
exactement qu'est ce qu'on fait ou on se
campe dans snow lens c'est quoi le style
des le style lyrique c'est super c'est
super consciente les factions ce qu'est
la dimension conceptuelle site bande et
plus et puis considéré là bas sont plus
intelligents
materi les cigarettes les 8 à
matéri là dessus c'est que ici le monde
et que l'union était tellement important
dans la culture populaire que ça rend du
sac à main stream mais les gens ils
identifient plus sincères comme étant
l'absurde ou pas il est juste passé
c'est de l'humour alors qu'elle a boy a
pas eu ce phénomène à
grande échelle c'est rester mince pies
de l'absurde
il fait catherine que l'absurde labaki
l'incroyance ouais effectivement qui est
d'ailleurs vraiment l'influencent pas
mal je sais
précieuse à mailhac marche
c'est quoi le secret de la longévité
votre danse que cette les mêmes membres
depuis depuis les bus finalement on
était des amis avant le bain
j'en étais encore avec ce fameux
énormément est-ce que vous nourrissez
vos thèmes toujours activement en ce
sens que si c'est conscient déjà avoir
vécu je n'étais quand j'ai vu où on
n'est pas obligé d oasis et on n'est pas
obligé de céder ce pour avoir eu envie
de se voir les normes et oui
effectivement j'ai envie d'un barbecue y
avait il y avait c'est vrai que des fois
on a des idées on se voit beaucoup et
club en effet le festival aussi
on se voit aussi de nascar de l'opinion
à limiter un conte fait on aussi les
mains a mis au maniement un email on a
beaucoup beaucoup d'amis en commun qui
tape du secondaire ne se fait que la
fête de tout le monde qui ait pas eu de
tout le monde les barbecues du monde on
se voit partout une professionnelle
jamais pris le dessus sur la gagne déjà
sa vie conjointement inquiet aussi si on
fait jouer à paris un
[Musique]
fait un one off à paris c'est la
dernière fois qu'on est allé on est allé
passer trois jours à londres ensemble
c'est laid je mange et boit des verts
qui se promener le tpiy s'il échoue on
va les voir genre wifi ou speed rail the
chicago y voler quatre ans en faction on
note des activités ont fait des lacs à
l'épaule des activités parascolaires
c'est vrai qu'il ya je pense qu'avec
avec toutes ces années leur côtoyé au
6ème année c'est que on n'est pas obligé
de forcer since ans maintenant on a
envie de voir ça fait un moment s'est
pas vu on s'enferme à habituer parce
qu'on on a deux joueurs de se conter ce
qui s'est passé dans cette semaine à
quai il ya comme je pense que cette
dimension mais pauvre rêve mais pour
n'est pas obligé de la là forcément fait
d'une chose nous ayons fait tellement
chaud on fait tellement d'autres
ensembles qui a été même si pendant
trois semaines on n'a pas de show puis
cécile honte au mois de février ouart et
woerth c'est sûr que si je passe par
drummondville vote explicitement total
est de banda aceh européenne sexuelle
avait elle va débarquer ou les verts
cela ses factures on se voit comme ça
mais c'est on n'a pas besoin de forcer
les choses parce que les résistances
voit comme cinq fois plus qu'à n'importe
quel moyen il avait erré dans la ville
était comme un bond de fiat en partant
avec le band qui festoient mais c'est
cool ça j'ai le dossard je sais pas mais
steam
moi j'ai tout le temps été dans des
projets ou est ce que maintenant il ya
un artiste qui comme le leader l'as de
projet puis nous on joue avec métier
c'est une décision c'est quelqu'un qui
tranche et c'est cette personne mais qui
plonge maintenant mais un band c'est
comme car tout le monde de son écoute
des fois inquiet de
ce nom pas
si on est quand même tout incident
fonctionner un plus un consensus ouais
ouais si ceux ci une décision qui fait
vraiment chier quelqu'un en fait paul
takaya comme si il ya ce côté le
artistiquement c'est rarement un
problème inquiète aussi c'est comme si
mon écrit tonnes et comme cissé s'est
nettement celle
l'orientation artistique des trois
accords c-26 mans qui mène la danse on
le fait
parce que tu dis quoi mais après s'il ya
tout le reste et que c'est sûr que quand
en studio c'était en
cédant nos propositions par en partie
mon gars le ty en section mix alexandre
dans les arrangements avec gosses sorti
il ya un pote qui est là mais là la toon
ça laisse la tonne ces exercices mans
avait fait 79 puis s'était
il l'avait fait avec je parle d'art yves
saint thois avec drive ça sonnerait plus
d'arize mais ça resterait le même sujet
est la même c'est ça serait juste comme
pirates puis tu sais vous allez voir ce
qu'il y a
il ya ça
m'est resté
la décision d'aller faire un
aller-retour à chibougamau font un
festival on en parle ensemble ce n'est
pas
le talent et le succès samedi au
quai festival en ou
[Musique]
non un autre festival
avant de laisser les guerres 15e édition
quinzième année peu importe comment vous
le dire gros line à chi chi chi chi et
là on en a parlé avant mais là pour les
gens qui nous écoutent qu'on est en
étant non
car cette année c'est harry endroit ils
y sont taris
ben voilà on l'a vu d'autres jouets que
sa gangue s'ils font beaucoup de parité
mai sont très proches nous on est dans
toutes les groupes charpy pôle
fait que houari endroit dans cette
soirée l'est vraiment cool c'est le
jeudi 2
501 loto-québec la scène hydro québec
ailleurs au québec fneeq bien aimé le
bilodeau sur cette scène l'homme à la
salle en solo jean marc lainé au noir
qui m'ont tout cas cette année avec son
album cas le valais voit les noms éric
lapointe vidange vidange axa la note
alban
avec
avec les examens sow
devrait voir beaucoup de bière sur cette
salle et vendredi nous on est là on est
avec lui adriano puis bon enfant je
passais top de fred
lary qui depuis est coriace sur le fait
que ce vendredi puis le samedi on earth
one is home du bar lannoy empilade sur
la scène hydro-québec sur le
sur la scène loto québec sur la scène au
québec on a rose pêche à venir voire
même impressionnant lors à 100 depuis
ariane moffatt nous fait vraiment la
place au hip hop c'est sur les niveaux
soit il ya une chose à l'époque jean
bce c'est beau mais c'est de moins en
moins rare mais ça a été écartée
longtemps quant à nous on a toujours
fait depuis le début cette année avec
une belle offre ça se passe et ça c'est
comme naturellement à l'univers ce
métier c'est si bon choix éditorial
c'est comme un petit âne il ya plein de
trucs cool qui se passe dans les peuples
qu'on va avancer là dedans petit peu
plus que d'habitude mais non mais en
général si justin on l'intègre de
manière à peu près équitable est ce qu
il reste encore 20 des pass pour les
trois jours oui en reste il y en a plus
en prévente mais il y en a au prix
régulier puis les gens ont fait leurs
valises
point commun entre les infos puis
acheter les billets là aussi on
recommande quand même acheter des
billets parce que c'est des fois quand
c'est les emplois de billets ça que le
toit se peut des fois confirmé qu'on
ferme les portes si c'est plein fois que
ça arrive assez souvent quand même des
dernières éditions c'est mieux ne pas
prendre de chance ce cas ariane leroy
joue exactement sur le
web est
je pense qu'elle ait laissé mieux
prévoir en fait
non mais venez avec moi j'ai pas trouvé
ça parce que quand même l'aspect poutine
aussi à exiger le natif foutraque qui te
sens c'est vraiment un triés sur le
volet la fac c'est pas une personne va
mal paraître la bonne voie
quel pays allait jouer qu'avec gagnant
de la fourchette sharks étaient de
retour pour défendre ça commence à être
magané les choix qu'on fasse un meeting
que les restaurateurs car il ne fallait
pas que notre force c'était
tourner
la fierté pour vous de gagner sa vie
j'ai l'impression fétis comme un la
fourchette basse n'ouvrait fourchette en
laiton c'est qu'on a fait faire à voir
des étudiants
commencent à peine à changer mairie mais
l'embouteillage de prix l'outillage de
machin truc si c'est lui qui en fait la
fourchette ça vient d'un bloc massif de
laiton c est dur à péter mensah kama
tout libre dans son chipset
manning et donne un charme
mairesse et prestigieux sont ils sont
vraiment motivés les restaurateurs s'y
colle aussi parce que c'est
vraiment drôle c'est que c'est de tout
le volet musical les gens viennent
pilotis découvrez la ferme se met les
côtés poutine aussi que nous on avait en
faisant a tourné aussi on se dit qu'ils
feront une vie de quelqu'un qui nous
parle de la poutine ils ont tout dit ou
l'arrière la meilleure exactement l'on
disait les gens m'ont emmené puis vont
cesti n'est malade parce que les gens
ils vont coûter des affaires
mais je ne sais vraiment comme une
course enlevante d'accueil il ya aussi
du salut ouais c'est vraiment cool fait
qu' il doit les laisser pour les gens
qui venaient très cool merci beaucoup
les gars aient bien c'est vraiment le
fun merci beaucoup